madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce jeudi 22 juillet
les cendres de john kennedy junior de
son épouse et de sa belle-soeur jeté à
la mer sur les lieux de l'accident
au cours d'une cérémonie que la famille
kennedy a voulu la plus sobre possible
peut-être la fin de la dépendance pour
les drogués des chercheurs français met
au point une molécule qui agirait sur le
cerveau et compenserait l'effet de
manque
les autorités chinoises déclare la
guerre à la secte falun gong d'une secte
qui revendique 80 millions d'adeptes à
travers toute la chine
les arrestations et les manifestations
se multiplient en ce moment même et puis
nous irons à la feria de mont-de-marsan
voir ce que sont les festaïres ces
fêtards qui sont en fait la main de ses
fête gasconne john kennedy junior ne
voulait pas d'obsèques nationales ni de
cérémonial au cimetière d'arlington il
ne reposera donc pas aux côtés de son
père à washington la famille a opté pour
une cérémonie relativement discrète en
pleine mer les cendres de john john
kennedy de son épouse de sa belle soeur
ont été jetés à l'océan pascal douce est
bon et loire perrin tranquillement le
clan prend place à bord de la navette en
tête le sénateur ted kennedy le chef de
famille et surtout caroline kennedy
schlossberg la soeur de john john c'est
elle qui a souhaité l incinération de
son frère et cette cérémonie en mer
c'est elle également qui a insisté pour
que les cendres de caroline et loren b
cette phase le même voyage
les deux familles embarque une demi
heure plus tard sur le ss briscoe un
destroyer de la navy john kennedy père a
servi dans la marine d'où l'accord du
pentagone qui d'habitude n'accepte pas
sur ces navires de funérailles civiles
une preuve supplémentaire des liens
indéfectibles entre le destin des
kennedy et celui de l'amérique de la
cérémonie on ne verra rien de plus les
cendres des trois victimes sont
dispersés à 8000 de gueye raid la plage
favorite de john-john à quelques
encablures du lieu du crash
au même moment à new york le parterre de
fleurs grandi de minute en minute à
tribeca devant le domicile du couple
disparu
plus au nord dans manhattan les
habitants du quartier de l'église
saint-thomas smur savent que la
cérémonie de demain sera strictement
privé quelques-uns souhaitait tout de
même s'y associer ou sont venus en
simples curieux
personne ici ne reste indifférent à
l'événement et avant d'être incinéré les
trois corps ont été autopsiés on sait
maintenant que leur mort a été
instantanée reste maintenant avec
l'épave de l'appareil qui était retrouvé
à déterminer les circonstances exactes
de l'accident parce qu'elle joue c'est
bon vous êtes à new york on a donc
assisté à une cérémonie presque discrète
pour un kennedy
la presse a été tenue à l'écart à plus
de 8 kilomètres de ce croiseur américain
ouais en fait ce qui faisait peur aux
famille kennedy et ben ça n'était pas
tant le spectacle de la cérémonie
auxquels ils sont habitués
mais bien sûr auquel elles sont
habituées par parlons mais c'était
plutôt l'exploitation possible de
l'émotion par la presse américaine qui
faisait peur à chacun des membres et
famille kennedy et baisse est
particulièrement ceux de la famille
bessette d'ailleurs ce matin un ami la
famille kennedy évoquèrent léger
désaccord entre caroline kennedy
schlossberg la soeur de john john et son
oncle le sénateur peut-être justement
sur le caractère public ou non qu'il
fallait donner à ses funérailles
finalement c'est caroline qui a eu le
dernier mot et qui a obtenu deux chacun
des membres du clan une relative
discrétion
alors parce qu'elle est ce que des
cérémonies plus officielle en tout cas
plus accessibles sont prévus pour plus
américain puisse rendre hommage à john
john kennedy
oui ce soir à new york cette nuit heure
française aura lieu un service funèbre
public dans une église de tribeca le
quartier où résidait le couple
aujourd'hui disparu et puis demain la
cérémonie de symptômes à ce mur sera
elle totalement privée avec seulement
deux invités en plus de la famille mais
deux invités de marque
hillary et bill clinton l'église saint
thomas more à manhattan a été préféré à
la cathédrale saint patrick
tout simplement parce qu'il s'agissait
de la paroisse de jacky kennedy onassis
la mère de john john l'épousé de john
fitzgerald kennedy
merci pascal c'est un espoir pour tous
les drogués compris les consommateurs
d'alcool et de tabac une équipe de
chercheurs français de l'inserm
travaille sur une molécule
révolutionnaire baptisé bp 897 en
agissant sur le cerveau elle
compenserait l'effet de manque ressenti
par tous les drogués pendant leur
sevrage sans pour autant être assimilés
aux traitements classiques de
substitution que sont la méthadone ou le
subutex les explications de géraldine
d'alban morenas et de didier rancoeur
dix ans de recherches sur des rats
cocaïnomane pour une découverte le bp
897 une molécule qui pourrait
bouleverser le traitement de la
toxicomanie
jusqu'à maintenant les usagers de
drogues ne disposait que de produit de
substitution comme la méthadone
uniquement destiné à combler un manque
la nouvelle molécule s'attaque elle à
l'origine même du processus de
dépendances elle va réduire
spécifiquement le besoin et l'envi en
particulier lorsque ce besoin et des
suscité par la présentation de signaux
qu'on était qui ont été préalablement
fortement associée à la prise de drogue
des études ont en effet montré qu'à la
simple but d'une seringue ou de billets
de banque
les usagers de drogues est immédiatement
une sensation de manque
le bp 897 éliminerait ses pulsions
administré sous forme de cachets il
remonterait jusqu'au cerveau et agirait
sur la région clé de la dépendance chez
l'être humain
mais l'utilisation de ce médicament
pourrait dépasser le strict cadre de la
cocaïne
en agissant sur d'autres dépendances
comme l'alcoolisme ou le tabagisme un
avenir prometteur donc à condition que
les résultats observés chez le rat se
confirme chez l'homme
le produit va être essayé chez l'homme
dès la rentrée dès le mois de septembre
chez le drogué vers la fin de l'année et
il faudra attendre probablement si tout
se passe bien
trois ou quatre ans pour que le produit
soit disponible le couramment chez les
personnes qui en auraient besoin
mais les expériences menées jusqu'ici
laisse une question sans réponse
le bp 897 va-t-il définitivement
supprimer la dépendance ou va-t-il
simplement l'atténuer après coca cola
c'est danone qui est touchée par une
affaire de moisissures dans ses produits
la sphère ne concerne que le marché
polonais depuis le début de la semaine
70 tonnes de fromage blanc de la marque
ont dû être retirés puis pour coca cola
les choses ne vont pas fort non plus
l'union européenne soupçonne la firme
d'abus de position dominante dans
plusieurs pays d'europe et une enquête
est ouverte
nous parlions hier de les clips cette
fameuse éclipse du 11 août qu'il ne
faudra rater sous aucun prétexte
mais regarder une éclipse peut être très
dangereux pour les yeux on risque même
la cécité
le gouvernement engage n'ont qu'une
grande campagne d'information sur les
dangers de les clips s'il faudra se
munir de lunettes spéciales
35 millions de paires vont être vendus
au prix maximum de 5 francs et 4
millions seront distribués gratuitement
aux enfants dans les centres de vacances
françoise valais et daniel lévy
la nuit en plein jour comme au mexique
en 91 les clips se produira à la mi
journée
le phénomène est simple un alignement
parfait entre le soleil la lune et la
terre
l'ombre de la lune va balayer une bande
de 110 km de large au nord de paris
c'est ce que l'on appelle la zone de
totalité ailleurs les clips ce sera
partiel l'événement est exceptionnel
mais attention aux yeux
en temps normal la lumière intense du
soleil ne permet pas de le regarder de
manière prolongée
mais au moment de l'éclipsé l'astre
étant partiellement recouvert par la
lune son observation est supportable à
l'oeil nu et là est le danger ici au
fond de l'oeil 70 brune est une brûlures
de la rétine suite à l'observation d'une
équipe les rayons du soleil ont brûlé
les cellules ils ont détruites
éventuellement un endroit et ça fait une
donc une comme un petit trou en plein
milieu de la rétine regarder une éclipse
quelque chose de très attirante quelque
chose d'un petit peu magique
donc les gens le regardent très
facilement il n'y a pas de douleur au
fur et à mesure de l'observation et donc
les dégâts qui sont dus au rayonnement
infrarouge du soleil qui n ont brûlé
cette partie centrale de la rétine se
font sans même que l'on s'en rende
compte et sans même que l'on ressent la
brûlure et quelques dizaines de secondes
d'exposition directe suffit pas question
de regarder en plusieurs fois l'effet
cumulatif même recouvert à 90 où 80%
le soleil est dangereux il faut donc se
protéger partout en france si vous êtes
à strasbourg si vous êtes à marseille si
vous êtes je sais pas à bordeaux par
exemple on aura là
le problème de voir le soleil à l'oeil
nu ce sera très dangereux donc il faut
se protéger
par contre les personnes qui seront sur
la bande de totalité auront deux minutes
pendant lesquelles elles verront le
soleil à l'oeil nu et à ce moment-là ça
cette lumière là est très affaibli et
donc n'est pas dangereuse mais prudence
après l'équipe au moment où le soleil
réapparaît à nouveau là depuis 7 ans
dilater dans la pénombre un maximum de
rayons peut se passer et brûler la
rétine à bannir absolument toutes les
lunettes de soleil même superposés pour
éviter les lésions oculaires une seule
solution porter des lunettes spéciales
avec le label ses heures afin que le
spectacle reste un merveilleux souvenir
l'actualité à l'étranger c'est d'abord
cette guerre déclarée par les autorités
chinoises à la secte falun gong une
secte de plus en plus puissantes en
chine qui prospère dans le vide laissé
par l'abandon progressif de lieux de
l'idéologie communiste
elle revendique 80 millions d'adeptes et
depuis deux jours
manifestations et arrestations se
multiplient le reportage est signée
bernard lebras notre équipe sur place
dirigé par isabelle besner a été
empêchée de travailler
ces images ont été tournées avec la plus
grande discrétion et bien sûr un a su
des autorités chinoises dans les bus des
dizaines d'adeptes qui ont été
rassemblés dans un stade par la police
tous sont membres du mouvement mystique
appelé falun gong terme chinois
d'origine bouddhiste que l'on peut
traduire par société de la roue de la
loi ou de la loi rotative secte ou vaste
club de gymnastique les adeptes du falun
gong semble bien inoffensifs
il pratique les arts martiaux dans la
rue en groupe il est vrai mais dans le
plus grand silence
ce qui gêne les autorités ce sont les
idées prônées par ce mouvement qu'il
qualifie de sectes moyenâgeuse hostiles
au progrès et qui annonce la fin du
monde depuis trois jours en chine
la police a lancé de grandes rafles
contre les adeptes du falun gong
il y à un nombre de contrôles d'identité
absolument incroyable clairement les
autorités redoutent de nouvelles
manifestations de masse de gens qui
seraient venus de province pour réclamer
qu'on reconnaisse ce mouvement du falun
gong qui vient d'être banni
on essaie ce matin la télévision
chinoise a ouvert ses programmes en
annonçant la décision du gouvernement
créé en 1992 le fallait on désormais
classé organisation illégale et dirigé
par cet homme li hongzhi cet ancien
militaire n'est dit il ou même jour que
bouddha vit désormais en exil
il dirige des états unis via internet
c'est 100 millions d'adeptes dans le
monde dont 80 pour l'unique chine selon
pékin il ne serait que 2 millions le
parti a tranché le seul art martial de
masse et de rue autorisé et le tai chi
dont on voit ici sur la place tiananmen
dans un ordre très martial une parfaite
démonstration officielle
au deuxième jour de sa tournée africaine
jacques chirac et inaugurait le barrage
de garafiri en guinée une réalisation de
la france pour permettre à la guinée de
réduire sa dépendance vis-à-vis de
l'énergie thermique ferro lixing tall
yves et jean corps du 75 mètres de haut
grâce aux nouveaux barrages de garafiri
3 millions de guinéens sur le tiers du
pays recevront l'électricité à partir de
décembre prochain avec une aide de 250
millions de francs la france est le
premier partenaire de cet ouvrage
lâché par la banque mondiale en cours de
route alors l'accueil au président de la
république c'est aussi la manifestation
d' enthousiasme de ce qui attend depuis
si longtemps
la modernisation de leur pays nous
croyons à la nécessité de maintenir une
aides publiques substantielles pour
soutenir les pays qui se réforme qui se
modernisent pour consolider les acquis
de la démocratie et du développement
les préserver des crises qui
malheureusement les affects trop souvent
la misère endémique en guinée est en
effet accru par le poids des réfugiés
des guerres voisine près de 700 mille
hommes femmes et enfants souvent
estropiés soignés dans des conditions
précaires et qui à la sortie ne trouvent
pas de travail après la guinée jacques
chirac s'envole pour le togo une étape
controversée puisque le président de la
république sera reçu par le général
eyadéma qui tient son pays d'une main de
fer et qui est actuellement mise en
accusation par amnistie internationale
je suis rac est donc arrivé tout à
l'heure au togo le togo qui se dit
maintenant prêt accepté sur son sol une
commission d' enquête indépendante pour
répondre justement aux accusations
d'amnesty international sur les
violations répétées des droits de
l'homme dans ce pays
pour l'anniversaire de l'alunissage de
la mission apollo 11 une équipe de
secours a réussi à récupérer la capsule
liberty bell par 4800 mètres de fond
liberty bell c'était cette capsule
spatiale à bord de laquelle virgil
grissom dans la lignée d'alan shepard
avait effectué ou plutôt un vol ou
plutôt un bon suborbital à 188 km
d'altitude c'était le 21 juillet 61 pour
les états unis
il s'agissait alors de répondre à la
première historique du russe youri
gagarine le 12 avril
on connaît la suite telle aventure
d'apollo 11 en revanche les choses ne
vont pas très bien du côté de cap
canaveral la scoumoune semble s'être
abattue sur la navette columbia qui
vient de connaître un deuxième un
deuxième report en une semaine
le dixième depuis l'an dernier et
dominique barrau ils ont les mêmes
sourires les mêmes salut que
l'avant-veille mail enthousiasme et
émoussés il faut dire que c'est la
seconde fois que les cinq membres
d'équipage endossent leurs scaphandres
de vol près au grand départ vers
l'espace pour rester à terre mardi le
déclenchement par erreur d'un signal
d'alarmé avait arrêté le compte à
rebours à six secondes du décollage
ce matin à 6h30 heure française c'est
l'orage qui a stoppé la mise à feu cinq
minutes avant l'heure prévue du compte à
rebours tout s'est très bien passé mais
d'un point de vue météo c'était pas le
bon moment
on restera une nouvelle fois dans 24 mai
mme hillary clinton était revenue tenter
d'assister au départ de la première
navette dont le commandant de bord est
une femme
en fait la mission dont le départ était
prévu à l'origine pour novembre de
l'année dernière a déjà été reportée à
huit reprises
déception donc en france au centre
national d'études spatiales qui
participe en envoyant un spationaute
nous encore une fois déçu pour michel
tonini qui effectivement notre
astronautes qui doit embarquer à bord de
cette mallette et qui a subi depuis
presque un an maintenant tous les
avatars rencontrer à la fois par le
satellite qui est à bord d'un arrêté qui
dote cette mise en orbite et puis
maintenant donc ces reports successifs
de lancement le dernier échec a encore
coûté 300 mille dollars un peu moins
2 2 millions de francs sur un coût total
de 2 milliards 750 millions de francs
la prochaine tentative est programmée
demain 6 heures 24 heures françaises
malgré des risques d'orage de 30%
c'est sans doute la dernière chance de
départ avant mi août
il est fortement déconseillé pour ne pas
dire interdit d'utiliser un téléphone
portable dans un avion pour avoir refusé
d'obtempérer un britannique vient d'être
condamné à 12 mois de prison ferme par
un tribunal de manchester c'est une
première outre manche il avait refusé
obstinément d'éteindre son appareil
malgré les demandes répétées de
l'équipage
il faut dire que un portable en vol peut
perturber les instruments électroniques
de l'appareil des instruments qui gère
par exemple le pilotage automatique
l'altitude où la pressurisation
les explications de fabrice fausses et
de gilbert russe ordinateur portable sur
les genoux téléphones mobiles soudé à
l'oreille les nouvelles technologies
sauve les passagers de l'ennui pour eux
la peine de prison infligée aux clients
peu gentleman de british airways est
excessive
mais il accepte le principe d'une
punition on n'est pas à cinq minutes
près quand même qu'on peut pas attendre
vous comment l'art et l'appareil est mal
vu entendu les brouilles dans les
haut-parleurs
les sommes sont manquait réellement
besoin de faire face au mieux prenant
aujourd'hui la plupart des passagers
savent qu'il est interdit d'utiliser son
portable dans l'avion et à ceux qui
l'oublient l'hôtesse est là pour le
rappeler
mesdames messieurs l'utilisation
d'appareils électroniques portatifs
n'est autorisé qu'en croisière usage des
téléphones mobiles est interdit et leur
alimentation doit être impérativement
coupé et pour les incrédules
voici la démonstration du commandant de
bord alors les décors p7 présente sa
chambre
mais on le savait
ce temps
j'en ai assez le wef démonstration de la
tipp et de l'utilisation d'un d'un
portable même imaginer que
cette émission les premiers coups va
perturber à ce point le matériel avec
navigation
il pourrait y avoir ce que l'on appelle
un glissement de cartes et
éventuellement une déviation de
trajectoire pour l'appareil mais il
s'agit là d'un scénario catastrophe
aucun incident majeur n'a encore est
attribué un téléphone portable
en france les compagnies aériennes sont
inquiètes elles pourraient à leur tour
se tourner vers la justice si les
tribunaux estiment que les autres
passagers ont été mises en danger la
condamnation peut aller jusqu'à un an de
prison et 100 mille francs d'amendé
et puisque nous parlons de téléphone
sachez que france télécom voudrait faire
payer à ses abonnés la pose de la
seconde prise téléphonique celle
notamment qui sert à internet
l'information est révélée par la cgt
mais elle n'est pas démentie par la
direction de france télécom qui affirme
qu'aucune décision n'a encore été prise
dans la sphère stranieri les corps
découvert dans le jardin d'une auberge
de l'aveyron sont bien ceux des anciens
propriétaires il avait disparu depuis le
12 avril après avoir vendu leur auberge
justement alfredo stranieri c'est la
suite logique de la baisse de
rémunération du livret a est cette fois
c'est une bonne nouvelle puisque le
crédit lyonnais la société générale et
la bnp ont déjà annoncé aujourd'hui la
baisse de leur taux de base
interbancaire
il passe de 6,55 à 6 95%
une décision dont se félicite dominique
strauss kahn alors que la consommation
des ménages a baissé en juin 2006 je
vous ai dit 5 6 95 c'était bien sûr 5,95
les vacances c'est aussi la période des
fraudes en tous genres les inspecteurs
de la répression des fraudes intensifie
donc leur contrôle un peu partout en
france c'est le cas par exemple sur
l'île de ré où cyrille devaud et
frédéric faure se sont rendus traverser
le pont de l'île de ré 110 francs pour
une voiture
gratuit pour un vélo et d'aller c'est
économique et sa demande peu d'effort
lille est parfaitement plate
beaucoup de vacanciers loue donc une
bicyclette et ça ne se passe pas
toujours
ils ont payé 130 francs pour la
demi-journée et il s'est mis à pleuvoir
le contrat est signé la maison ne
rembourse pas je suis arrivée ses
clients mécontents après le soudain que
nous réalisons un reportage avec un
inspecteur des fraudes
finalement c'est lui qui va régler le
conflit
s'il a pas envie que ça se présente
généralement que les jours de mauvais
temps
ou sinon il ya le même litige qui se
présente quand y'a un problème mécanique
pour limiter les problèmes
thierry rue terre contrôler
régulièrement les lourds de cycle phare
frein sonnette l'inspection dure 20
minutes peu d'amande surtout des
avertissements pouces en revanche on ne
plaisante pas avec les restaurants
thierry rue terre et ses collègues en
ont déjà contrôlé 250 depuis le début de
l'été sur la carte de celui ci des
poissons et des fruits de mer annoncés
comme produits frais on peut s'attendre
à ce que ce sont des produits qui
viennent de la dernière marée est en
fait ce sont parfois des produits qui
viennent directement du congélateur une
seule façon de vérifier
thierry rue terre demandent au chef
cuisinier de lui ouvrir la porte de ses
chambres froides
personne ne peut lui en interdire
l'accès
fouillez questionner la curiosité c'est
parait-il la première qualité du métier
regard leur état de fraîcheur
langoustines qui ça ne date pas de trop
longtemps bon là priori c'est bien la
température là normalement c'est un
frigo pour denrées périssables
normalement ces quatre degrés une petite
côte qui ne coûtera qu'un petit
avertissement
la sanction pour une grosse infraction
250 mille francs et deux mois de prison
les dix enquêteurs de charente-maritime
effectué 1000 contrôles chaque été ils
constatent une ou plusieurs infractions
dans 10 % des cas
comme chaque année les gorges de
l'ardèche sont envahies de touristes
certains les font à pied pour elle mais
la plupart en canoë
l'endroit est magnifique mais il peut
s'avérer dangereux 5 personnes s'y sont
déjà noyés depuis le début de l'été le
reportage de didier guyot et de gilles
perret les gorges de l'ardèche donnait
septembre ce sont quelques trois cent
mille personnes qui chaque année se
lance à l'assaut de ses 34 km en une ou
deux journées les adeptes du canoë-kayak
affronter rapides de la rivière
mais à trop penser aux vacances beaucoup
en oublient les règles élémentaires de
sécurité
j'irai équipe avoue le gilet de
sauvetage est obligatoire et peut sauver
une vie
on n'a jamais retrouvé un noyer qui
portait un gilet de sauvetage se plaît
c'est à dire les secouristes trop
souvent les touristes l'oubli autres
règles de sécurité savoir nager havre la
condition physique sans oublier que les
enfants de moins de 7 ans n'ont pas le
droit d'être ici moins de 7 ans c'est
très important
on voit trop souvent des enfants des
parents inconscients qui amènent des
enfants très très jeune et ça nous
surprend beaucoup et
et on est obligé d'intervenir
les rangs d'un petit velours d'urgence
arrêter des mesures de prudence et de
sécurité qu'il est parfois difficile à
faire comprendre en temps le site pareil
dulic nous tissons mena tout au long de
l'année on voit bien qu'il ya des
personnes qui parfois se noie qui ont
des problèmes qui se blesse et on a tout
ça en tête ne l'ont pas tant mieux parce
qu'ils sont en vacances mais c'est quand
même notre rôle de leur rappeler qu'on
ne peut pas faire n'importe quoi et 18h
enferme 18h le règlement est ainsi fait
plus aucun cas nous et ne peut entrer
dans les gorges
certains soirs les récalcitrants sont
nombreux les gendarmes vers 18 heures
c'est aussi le moment où les gardes de
la réserve prennent possession des lieux
objectif principal empêcher le camping
sauvage obliger les touristes à
s'installer sur les bivouacs autorisée
si on arrive à maîtriser sa
fréquentation
on va pouvoir à nos compatibles et
fréquentation et protection
d'environnement
si on laissait déborder par côté
fréquentation
je dirais c'est l'environnement c'est la
réserve naturelle c'est des espèces
d'ici devront payer en début de soirée
une fois les touristes disparu un aigle
prendra son envol après la sur
fréquentation de la journée les gorges
respire la nature devient enfin plus
paisible à trieste en italie la
curiosité sans doute sur la plage c'est
en effet le dernier endroit d'italie et
peut-être même d'europe ou hommes et
femmes ne peuvent pas se baigner
ensemble chacun bronze de son côté ce
qui semble t-il ajoutent du piquant à la
sphère alain de chalvron et dominique
bahl la lanterne celle établissements
balnéaires le plus ancien est toujours
le plus populaire de trieste
il y a comme autrefois une entrée pour
les femmes et une autre pour les hommes
seulement il ne s'agit pas seulement
d'entrée le vestiaire mais bien d'un
établissement pratiquant encore
l'apartheid sexuel les femmes à gauche
et les à ma droite un mur au milieu en
mer prolongé par un filet en principe
hermétique
côté dames c'est la foule pas un
centimètre carré disponible elle sent
pas cela comme nulle part ailleurs trop
peureuse apparemment d'être entre elles
et de se laisser aller à des libertés
peu courante dans cette partie d'italie
encore
un provincial et les hommes sont de leur
côté nous sommes ici nous parlons nous
nous jouons cartes nous y atteint
tricote et systèmes petit creux la
récession mais de l'autre côté du mur
côté hommes
on est beaucoup moins nombreux et loin
de vouloir embêter les voisines
bien sûr il y a les frustrés qui
essayent d'entrapercevoir une âme soeur
en vain il ya aussi celui qui reste
comme interdit devant l'infranchissable
frontières mais la majorité prend
tranquillement le soleil et joue aux
cartes entre misogyne fier de l'être
propre heureux de pouvoir se changer
sans contorsion
les femmes sont ennuyeuses mais femmes
ennuyeuse mieux vous laisser les hommes
entre eux en paix nous sommes très bien
comme ça c'est une si vieille tradition
les femmes nous avons toute la journée à
la mairie
c'est mieux de ne pas les avoir toujours
à nos côtés alors jusqu'à quand durera
cette tradition centenaire le bain fut
ainsi créée à la fin du siècle dernier
par l'armée autrichienne mais tout de
même un peu ringarde
à l'aube de l'an 2000 les femmes ont
voulu abattre le mur qui divise la plage
mais les hommes ont gagné ils ne veulent
plus jusqu'au moment où il se trouvera
un bataillon de dragueur impénitent pour
braver en masse l'interdît comme ce
courageux ou inconscient et laisser les
misogynes à leurs parties de cartes
voilà ça vous chante c'est à trieste le
tour de france bordeaux s'est offert une
fois de plus une arrivée au sprint c'est
le belge tom steels qui l'a emporté
après 200 kilomètres de plat travers les
landes au classement général rien ne
bouge en revanche à 15 cents mètres de
l'arrivée le sprinteur australien stuart
o'grady a été victime d'un spectateur
qui l'a aspergée d'un produit irritant
il est tombé et a sans doute perdu toute
chance de conserver son maillot vert
reportage de florent gautreau et de
philippe deslandes
c'est un doux rêveur un vrai naïf ou un
suicidaire en puissance le suisse 12
heures tente une échappée solitaire en
plein vignoble bordelais mais à 25 km de
l'arrivée la défaite est assurée
bordeaux est la mecque des sprinteurs
une chasse gardée
le français carlos da cruz qui courent
son premier tour n'a que faire des
traditions séculaires il se lance à la
poursuite de 12 heures
les angevins les sprinteurs qui ont eu
le courage de passer les alpes et les
pyrénées n'ont pas l'intention de
laisser une chance assez conquérant de
l'impossible à 14 kilomètres de
l'arrivée les deux hommes sont rejoints
par un peloton ravi de retrouver la
plaine des équipes de sprinteurs ont
roulé à fond dans les derniers
kilomètres provoquant même une chute
impressionnante mais sans gravité
les fous du guidon ont fait très fort
quant à 46,2 moyenne donc pour moi c'est
pas mal ça commence à faire des achats
de son bord on est parti tranquille
je pense que ça a dû faire le coq s'est
remis en marche - 12 48 de moyenne
c'est impressionnant quand on est à
l'intérieur vivement lundi
capelle 9e du sprint ne sera pas le
premier vainqueur français de ce tour il
n'a ni les équipiers de diabel ni la
puissance de style tom steels qui
remporte sa troisième victoire d'étape
s'impose pour la première fois à
bordeaux dans trois jours sur les champs
elysées au pourrait bien revoir la jolie
figure de stylistes et sur le plan du
dopage marie george buffet demande
officiellement à l'union cycliste
internationale d'avoir accès aux
contrôles sanguins effectués sur les
corps aux courbes du tour de france
une démarche revendiqué au nom de la
transparence et de la crédibilité
médicale et dans laquelle daniel balle
le président de la fédération française
de cyclisme lui apporte tout son soutien
en athlétisme on attendait christine
arron hier soir à charléty mais la
française n'a pas brillé dans le 200 m
en revanche genis barber a établi un
nouveau record de france en saut en
longueur en franchissant 7 mètres 0 1
julien est riche où marie-josé pérec est
juste là en spectatrice les yeux braqués
sur christine arron et marion jones
au départ du 200 m
en matière de sprint au féminin c'est ce
qu'on fait de mieux comme confrontation
mais la femme la plus rapide du monde
par les temps qui courent c'est bien
john l'américaine ar on termine 5e
déception aux championnats du monde dans
un mois la française s'alignera sur sa
distance favorite le 100 m histoire de
rivaliser d'un peu plus près avec la
reine du sprint devant 17000 spectateurs
parisiens
driss maazouzi s'est quant à lui su
repasser troisième dès 1500 mètres
remportée par le kenyan ngoni il bat son
propre record de france ses illustres
prédécesseurs se nomme bernard ou jazy
lourde tâche que de leur succéder
fraîchement naturalisée française eunice
barber s'est elle adjugé le concours du
saut en longueur 7 mètres 0-1 record de
france de bonne augure avant les
championnats du monde de séville où l'on
espère bien voir les bleus s'envoler
vers les médailles et nous maintenons
partons maintenant pour avignon avec une
pièce assez étonnante trois acteurs
jouent avec des pantins et croque les
travers de notre société du monde
politique ça s'appelle le rêve de votre
vie reportage de marie ngono et de jean
louis moulin
lucienne et nicolas juste avant d'entrer
en scène un petit tour dans l'exposition
de ces drôles de pontenx réalisé par
francis marshall bonjour françois lazaro
va leur donner une âme par la magie du
théâtre dans un vieux café voué à la
démolition monsieur l'élu a rassemblé
tout le quartier
il a un projet immobilier mais il fait
semblant de s'intéresser aux souhaits de
ses administrés
écrit des mots nouveaux écrivez-moi
auquel raconte je cadrais compte à paris
car c'est tout le jeu c'est de se mettre
à l'écouté de cette matière morte de
sept de ses de ces êtres dont on pense
d'habitude qu'ils sont des pantins des
parts de marché départ de consommation
des bouts de pourcentage et ils se
rendent compte que quand on les écoute
il se met à dire des choses vraiment
très belle et très humaine en fait plus
de république
on a un humour grinçant qui rappelle la
bande dessinée reiser wolinski fous les
ide au chaud les une pièce qui garde
aussi une place pour la tendresse
toi je t'ai voilà on appelle ça des
festaïres autrement dit des fêtards ils
sont l'âme des fêtes gasconne né des
férias même si de temps en temps la
fatigue se fait sentir michel mompontet
et jean-françois haussmann les ont
suivis dans la feria de mont-de-marsan
une semaine durant leur vie est épuisant
les festaïres fêtards en gascon sont
aisément reconnaissables et sa marque
foulard verrait bien sûr un goût
prononcé pour un certains détails qui
fait l'élégance aux festayres observons
en fêtard amateurs se lève tôt parce que
ce sont ces fêtes qui veut transmettre
aux festaïres dès demain l'esprit
l'esprit de la corne l'esprit de la
dérision mais aussi l'esprit du taureau
est vrai taureau ceux qui seront
combattus par de vrais professionnels
dans les arènes de la ville l'après-midi
attendre et aux abords des arènes les
futurs prestataires en attendant de
grandir apprennent que les taureaux vrai
ou faux sont bien le lien qui unit c'est
tout l'effet stable
tout ce qui est lié au jeu de la corne
automatiquement on se trouve dans le
cercle est ailleurs je crois que les
hommes brill
le plus gros spectacle authentique pur
et le plus tragique et plus rigolo
accord et puis ça y est la moins sérieux
on se bat pour vivre parce que pour voir
la star du moment où c'est thomas stores
et il faut avoir des sous pas mal de
sous pour accéder à ces arènes les
festaïres reçues souvent les toreros
mais de loin comme dans l'ombre sur les
gradins et quand la corrida s'achève
c'est à leur tour parfois de connaître
aussi quelques au lait et des viva sur
cette piste qu'il aurait un instant
offerte autres rites mais surtout
spectacle rafraîchissant de l'art de
faire la fête
un art pas si simple qu'il n'y paraît
une semelle toujours tradition et
parodies ça va faire à la fête c'est pas
donné à tout le monde mais quand on est
responsable de la fête et de savoir
accueillir les jeunes 2000 fonds et les
jeunes de l'accueil
il faut qu'ils se mettent à la coutume
du pays jusqu'au bout de la nuit
le vrai festin ne laissera personne en
dehors du cercle des chansons
pour re découvrir ensemble le simple
plaisir de s'amuser
une feria durant
à
voilà ces maisons la fin de cette
édition je vous en rappelle les deux
principaux titres les cendres de john
kennedy junior de son épouse de sa
belle-soeur jeté à la mer sur les lieux
de l'accident au cours d'une cérémonie
la famille kennedy a voulu la plus sobre
possible peut-être la fin de la
dépendance pour les drogués des
chercheurs français met au point une
molécule qui agirait sur le cerveau et
compenserait l'effet de manque dans un
instant la météo présentée par isabelle
martinez suivi du point haute de valérie
maurice à 20h55 les nouveaux mondes le
magazine présenté par antoine de maximy
vers 0 h 35 le journal de la nuit sera
présentée par m mais t'es d'min 7h50
dans les 4 vérités
marie pierre farkas recevra pierre andré
périssol ancien ministre vice président
du conseil général d'auvergne à 13h ce
serait bien sûr carole gaessler et
rachid arhab à 20h vous retrouverez
philippe lefait quant à moi j'ai le
plaisir de vous retrouver lundi bon week
end et bonne soirée sur france 2
l'image du héros